Now it's time for our pop quiz to make sure everyone
understands pop. For this quiz, assume that the name p refers to
a list with at least two elements. Your goal is to determine
which of the code fragments does not change the final value of
p. And so that means no matter what value p starts with,
as long as it has at least two elements after executing the
code. And I'll show you the choices for the code next. The
value of the p is the same as what it started with.
So here are the choices. Check the box for each
code fragment where the value of p at the end of
the code fragment is the same as the value of
p beforehand, assuming that initially p has at least two elements.